hi YouTube my name is ingrosso kanji
while managing director the World Bank
I'm very concerned about the impact of
the economic global financial crisis on
developing countries they're being if no
over in several ways first of all
commodity prices of oil in reading past
so many of them when sports natural
resource products and experiencing
declines in income in other price of
things like like cotton has fallen off
copper you name it Germany naturalist's
second channel many people in the
Diaspora who used to send money home and
nothing that anymore so remittances are
down for many governments hang out for
instances experience a full of forty
percent which is the last more time in
remittances and this is important and
then in addition foreign direct
investment is growing up so many
investments that we're going to be made
for example 350 million dollar
investment in Zambia these are no longer
going to be made so this means that
unemployment is going to be an issue in
many of the countries all I'm trying to
say is that we have one integrated world
and what is happening in the developed
countries is also impacting the
developing ones therefore when we think
of stimulus packages we need to think
not just of the developed countries but
also how can we help the development of
low income countries to have a stimulus
package as well you must remember that
these countries have also this offering
from a food crisis so you have financial
crisis overlaid on food crisis and we
need to make to make sure that the 1
billion people who don't have enough to
eat don't suffer any further now the
president of the world on cobb salad has
suggested that each develop Conchita has
a stimulus package devotes 0.7 percent
of it to help developing countries to
have their own stimulus so that dinner
and in this country's can also be
improved I think this is a good idea I'd
love to know what you think of it hope
to hear from some of you thank you